[Music]
Det Jamie Foxx was perfection as host
except for that moment needs and you got
me all excited about ve why what are you
gonna give us tonight because I know
there has to be a surprise well what's
crazy is Beyonce once again is gonna
open the show Beyonce from San
Bernardino though not the one you're not
gonna know the difference
Oh Jamie's got jokes okay so no Beyonce
in the house but she was amongst the
winners last night
be picked up best female R&B pop artist
[Music]
rapper Kendrick Lamar humbly took home
the most prizes including album of the
year while cardi B who just confirmed
her secret marriage to offset from the
rap group egos won best female hip-hop
artist in the film category Black
Panther also scored trophy first of all
I love the short it's good stuff
Tyra Banks rocked that Bob and showed
off her dynamic figure in a champagne
and gold Stello cat suit the supermodel
mommy also talked about bouncing at all
now that her son York is too is it a
terrible twos or is he skipping that
face I think every two-year-old has a
some terrible moment but he's also like
in charge
Tyra was on hand to present Best Actress
which went to Tiffany Haddish who
accepted via video
and in addition to hosting Jamie joined
Marsha Ambrosius
Ledisi and gospel singer Yolanda Adams
for an all-star tribute to army legend
and lifetime achievement honoree Anita
Baker
[Music]